Terminator en personne est venu
s'attaquer au nid de cool Arnold
Schwarzenegger a aidé son voisinage à
Los Angeles en comblant lui-même un trou
sur la route dans une vidéo publiée sur
son compte Instagram qui a fait
plusieurs millions de vues l'acteur de
75 ans montre qui est toujours en forme
l'ancien gouverneur de Californie en
avait visiblement marre d'attendre et a
préféré faire les travaux lui-même et
avec l'aide de son équipe comme il l'a
expliqué sur Twitter
[Musique]
c'est une mission terminée en fait
sonidpool que vous venez de voir ce
n'était pas un nid de poule
réalisée pour des travaux d'une
compagnie de base dans un quartier de
Los Angeles tranché qui servait à
évacuer les résidus d'un chantier pour
permettre l'amélioration des conduites
de gaz de cette de ce quartier de cette
mauvaise nid de poule de la ville
fatigue ils ont toujours quelque chose
je peux plus les voir allez regarde
derrière un zèbre l'autre il va tous les
jours chez le coiffeur l'autre on dirait
une pistache elle a toujours un truc une
fois c'est les dents une fois c'est le
coup une fois c'est mon cul l'autre
aussi
à 7 c'est un rendez-vous de débile
Bernard Montiel on sait même pas ce
qu'il fait et l'autre en tout cas allez
bon ben merci en tout cas vous voyez que
je suis le bonne humeur merci les chéris
d'être là
comme toujours il se gratte nerveusement
sa capuche aurait été un nom plus
approprié
[Musique]
il ne remarque même pas la présence de
la renarde
[Musique]
il ne peut plus s'arrêter
la vidéo que vous allez voir est assez
lunaire une jeune femme se file dans un
restaurant au moment où un membre de la
direction vers lui dire et bien qu'elle
mange trop
[Musique]
[__]
vous êtes allés trois fois la planche à
chacun donc pour nous c'est pas du tout
rentable
[Musique]
en tout cas vous êtes toujours servir
on pouvait pas prendre un dessert là
après l'accident lors d'une course
sauvage à Bordeaux vendredi soir le
conducteur du véhicule un homme de 32
ans a été mise en examen et placé en
détention provisoire jusqu'à sa
comparution en juin devant le tribunal
il était venu en spectateur assister à
ce qu'on appelle un run et après la
course il a décidé de faire des tours de
piste alors qu'il n'avait aucune
expérience c'est alors qu'il a perdu le
contrôle de son véhicule il a fait 13
blessés un bilan qui paraît presque
miraculeux
[Musique]
aient
ah bah ouais vous étiez occupé
une heure plus tard les deux renards
sont toujours ensemble
ils se sont accomplis mais reste collés
comme deux chiens après une saillie
se séparer peut prendre des heures
[Musique]
ils ne peuvent plus se détacher car
l'organe reproducteur de Red à enflé
tandis que celui de la renarde s'est
contracté
il se mordille ne sachant pas quoi faire
c'est gênant
ça casse un peu l'ambiance quand on voit
le moteur qui arrive à côté après
il parait que tu as proposé de venir
dans ton club pour adulte est-il venu
non il est pas venu dans mon club et je
le regrette énormément personne n'est
parfait après j'aimerais bien que
Marlène Chapa Vienne dans sa belle
petite robe blanche elle ferait son plus
grand effet allô c'est
Marley avec la polémique et la suscité
on pourra au moins dire de Marlène
Schiappa qu'elle a aidé la presse au
magazine Playboy on est plutôt content
le numéro d'avril juin avec Marlène
chapelle à la Une se vend très bien le
directeur du magazine affirme que les
100 000 exemplaires du mensuel se sont
quasiment tous vendus il affirme même
que ces numéros ont été vendus en
seulement trois heures après leur
arrivée en kiosque résultat aurait
imprime jeudi il paraîtront 60 000
nouveaux exemplaires du magazine ce qui
porte le tirage à 160 000 exemplaires
plus de 5 fois plus que d'habitude on a
pas le droit de me poser des questions
sur le physique blond brun troll nous on
a fait des paris on a une liste de
questions
un beau mec 25
[Musique]
de large
[Applaudissements]
de mosaïque comme ça avec un serpent qui
a été très beau ça veut dire quoi
surtout ça veut dire ferme ta gueule
on va être pressé parce qu'il a une
jambe de bois le temps qu'il arrive
jusqu'à ici
vous êtes pas au courant d'une autre
alors vous allez voir la jambe de bois
après vous comprendrez
on ouvre cette édition avec Jean-Marie
Le Pen que l'on voit ici soulever une
barre de 50 kg à la seule force de son
pénis
en fait ce sont des modules individuels
qu'on peut voilà assembler et en général
on va rarement au-delà de 4 mais c'est
assez sympathique
j'ai une force dans les mains c'est
impressionnant une tentative de triche
qui finit en échec et mat
un jeune kenyan s'est fait passer pour
une femme lors d'un tournoi d'échec un
aérobie caché sous un ni cab plusieurs
signes ont finalement trahi comme sa
carrure ou encore sa pointure 44 il
espérait remporter le prix de la
catégorie féminine moins relevé sur le
papier que la catégorie masculine dans
laquelle figurer plusieurs grands
maîtres après 4 tours une femme arbitre
il a pris à part et lui a demandé de
retirer son câble le fraudeur a tout de
suite avoué il risque plusieurs années
de suspension je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on fait pas jouer les hommes et
les femmes ensemble oui c'est bizarre
on a quand même des cerveaux qui
fonctionnent pareil
de niveau entre les hommes et les femmes
aux échecs qu'aux tennis mais je crois
je découvre ça ce matin
35 % des Français adhèrent à une théorie
du complot enfin ils disent 35% mais à
tous les coups c'est un chiffre trafiqué
par le gouvernement je le sais je l'ai
lu dans reptilien juif magazine mon
magazine préféré merci Charlotte
Gainsbourg merci Dany Boon